dagegen bei der union doch wer der neue
kanzler wird ist auch heute noch unklar
wir waren total aufgeregt weil ich
glaube dass war die spannendsten jahr
als die spannendste wahl seit vielen
vielen jahren schon deshalb
ein riesen wunder vollbracht meine wahl
wäre auch für laschet gewesen ja ich ein
bisschen enttäuscht dass ich hatte schon
gehofft dass die grünen stärker
abschneiden ich bin einigermaßen froh
dass es nicht rot rot grün geworden ist
ja ich glaube jamaika wird wird am
ersten passen ja ich glaube da sind die
meisten schnittmengen es gibt kein
gewinner es gibt kein verlierer und eine
dreier koalition ist für mich eine
katastrophe
ich habe angst wieder einmal vor einer
großen koalition weil sich die anderen
nicht einigen können guten abend
herzlich willkommen zum zdf spezial wer
kann und will mit wem die wählerinnen
und wähler haben die weichen auf wechsel
gestellt ohne dass so ganz klar ist was
genau das heißt um eine mehrheit
zustande zu bringen die nicht schon
wieder groko heißt müssen mehrere
parteien ihre komfortzone verlassen
wir sprechen darüber mit olaf scholz und
markus söder mit annalena baerbock und
volker wissing und schauen erst mal kurz
aufs endergebnis
die spd stärkste partei mit 25,7 prozent
die union nur noch an zwei mit 24,1 die
grünen jetzt drittstärkste kraft mit
14,8 die fdp wieder zweistellig mit 11,5
das ist die ausgangslage für die
parteien von den drei will regieren
werden fdp und grüne braucht dazu
ziemlich sicher geht das können aus
politischen erzgegner beste freunde
werden bernd benthin
ob rot oder schwarz ins kanzleramt kommt
darüber verhandeln jetzt grün und gelb
die strippenzieher der nächsten tage
bringen sich in stellung fdp und grüne
wollen vor sondieren
guten morgen allerseits in die runde am
tag danach
es ist eine gute idee dass diejenigen
die erst mal am weitesten weg sind auf
der politischen skala mal gucken ob sie
miteinander was hinkriegen und eine
brücke bauen können zwischen grünen und
fdp gibt es die größten inhaltlichen
unterschiede in der vergangenheit waren
sich grüne und fdp vor allem darüber
einig dass sie sich über kaum etwas
einig sind verbunden in herzlicher
abneigung die grünen die angebliche neue
volkspartei wir retten die welt liebe
freunde was für eine überheblichkeit mir
ist nicht klar mit welchen inhalten die
fdp antritt aber gab mitunter den
eindruck dass bullerbü leitbild sein
können winter hat ja immer das problem
dass im zweifelsfall weg läuft das muss
er selber klären letzte wallander
erinnerung auch im aktuellen deutschen
bundestag sind die grünen die kleinste
bundestagspartei nichts mit dem größten
maul
lukas köhler ist so etwas wie der grünen
verstehe bei der fdp er hat ein gelb
grünes gesprächsformat angestoßen die
sogenannte pasta connection köhler sagt
gemeinsame ziele gebe es war wir sehen
glaube ich dass wir ganz vielen punkten
in der ziel architektur gemeinsam folgen
können also zum beispiel beim
klimaschutz wir wollen beide ein
effizientes management der klimapolitik
und wir wollen vor allem beide das 1,5
grad ziel umsetzen und dafür eine
gemeinsame politik zu finden das ist
glaube ich zwischen grünen und uns
möglich allerdings bleiben große
differenzen die grünen wollen vermögende
stärker belasten die fdp schließt
steuererhöhungen aus die grünen wollen
das klima auch mit verboten schützen die
fdp will das explizit nicht ein
gemeinsamer nenner könnte die
bildungspolitik sein einheitlicher und
digitaler das wollen beide vor der wahl
betonte christian lindner für ein
bündnis mit grünen und spd fehle ihm
jegliche fantasie die grünen halten
genau dieses bündnis jetzt für deutlich
wahrscheinlicher wir stehen einer einer
spd nunmehr als
als der union wenn ich mir dieses
wahlergebnisse anschaut dann haben wir
gesehen die wählerinnen und wähler
wollten olaf scholz
eine personalfrage könnte noch zur
wichtigen verhandlungsmasse werden das
finanzministerium würden beide gerne
besetzen grüne und fdp
ich begrüße im studio den fdp
generalsekretär volker wissing guten
abend guten abend sie haben beste
chancen mitzuregieren aber dazu brauchen
sie die grünen mit denen sie inhaltlich
nicht so viel verbindet deshalb ja die
sogenannte vor sondierung wie soll das
ablaufen wir müssen sprechen welche
gemeinsamen ziele wir identifizieren
können ein dreierbündnis ist nicht
einfach aber machbar
am ende muss man sich auf einen konzept
verständigen das für das land einen
mehrwert bringt und das gilt es jetzt in
gesprächen zu klären wenn sie und die
grünen jetzt so eine art masterplan für
sich entwerfen und zu einem
fortschrittlichen zentrum werden wie das
ihr parteichef lindner nennt ist es dann
mehr oder weniger egal wer unter ihm
kanzler ist nein eine koalition kann
immer nur auf augenhöhe
funktionieren deswegen kann niemand
unten oder oben sein wichtig ist dass
wenn man ein dreierbündnis ausloten man
herausarbeitet was ist denn das
besondere dieses bündnisses was stellt
den mehrwert für die gesellschaft dar
eine regierung als reines zweckbündnis
das den kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner
sucht das genügt nicht um die großen
aufgaben zu bewältigen die heute vor uns
liegen sie haben ja immer die
schnittmengen mit der cdu betont die ist
aber nun mal der klare verlierer dieser
wahl ist nicht ein bündnis der drei
wahlsieger also mit spd und grünen
eigentlich auch der auftrag der wähler
naja parteien gewinnen und verlieren
wahlen am ende müssen wir aber als
verantwortliche politikerinnen und
politiker dafür sorgen dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger möglichst alle zu
gewinnern werden und darum geht es jetzt
und das ist eine inhaltliche frage sie
waren ja selbst minister in einer
spd-geführten ampel in rheinland pfalz
ist das eine ermutigung für seine
regierung im bund was sehr gute
erfahrungen die sie gemacht haben
sicherlich ist das eine erfahrung die
einen beitrag leisten kann um ein dreier
bis zu erarbeiten
wir haben in schleswig holstein eine
jamaika-koalition die sehr gut
funktioniert und in rheinland-pfalz
einer ampel in sachsen anhalt jetzt eine
deutschland koalition das gute signal
ist dass die parteien der demokratischen
mitte ganz offensichtlich in der lage
sind miteinander zu sprechen und auch
programme zu erarbeiten die das land
weiterbringen mit welcher konstellation
wir das im bund am besten erreichen das
müssen wir jetzt in gesprächen klären es
ist immer ganz wichtig dass
koalitionspartner zusammenarbeiten
wollen nur die rechnerische mehrheiten
zu addieren das reicht nicht aus denn in
der regel muss man nach abschluss eines
koalitionsvertrages probleme bewältigen
die man heute noch gar nicht kennt und
dann muss eine koalition
zusammenarbeiten wollen und können mit
der bitte um eine kurze antwort nach dem
scheitern von jamaika 2017 werden wir
haben ende doch wieder eine notgruppe
erleben da wir werden alles tun um das
zu verhindern
danke für das gespräch ich danke ihm
das gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet und jetzt begrüße
ich die grünen co vorsitzende und
spitzenkandidatin annalena baerbock hier
im studio guten abend
das kanzleramt ist außer reichweite aber
ihre partei ist gestärkt und kann mit
entscheiden wer mit wem regiert gab es
da schon gespräche hat sie zum beispiel
armin laschet kontaktiert es ist gut
dass immer alle miteinander reden aber
das wichtige bei gesprächen ist dass man
vertraulichkeit hat wir haben jetzt ja
ein ergebnis vorliegen das war gestern
nacht noch ein bisschen anders wo die
spd klar vorne liegt und deswegen werden
wir jetzt zum 1 auch mit der fdp sehr
zeitnah sprechen weil es wichtig ist
gerade bei den beiden parteien die am
weitesten auseinander stehen die ersten
gespräche zu führen und dann zeitnah
auch mit der spd wenn sie sich in den
vorgesprächen mit der fdp eingehen oder
sogar einigen ist dann eine wiederholung
des traumas von 2017 also die ewige
groko als notlösung ausgeschlossen
dieses land sehen sich ja nach einer
erneuerung nach acht jahren großer
koalition
endlich einen neuen aufbruch zu schaffen
und auch was neues zu wagen
dreierbündnisse das ist nicht nur
einfach aber es kann und auch das
momentum dafür geben dinge wirklich
anders zu machen nämlich zu definieren
ich weiß dass der kleinste gemeinsame
nenner sondern was es eigentlich unser
ziel und dieses land muss modernisiert
werden mit blick auf den klimaschutz
eine klimaneutrale wirtschaft gestalten
die gleichzeitig den wohlstand und den
zusammenhalt in unserem land sichert und
das ist eine große aufgabe die man
vielleicht mit einem neuen bündnis auch
noch einmal mit voller kraft und energie
ganz neu angehen kann das stichwort
würde ich gerne aufnehmen mit wem können
sie denn stand heute mehr klimaschutz
umsetzen und der spd mit der cdu
im wahlkampf an beide deutlich gemacht
dass sie sich nicht voneinander
entscheiden aber das wählervotum ist ja
klar und deutlich
ganz ganz viele menschen in diesem land
erwarten dass es endlich eine klima
regierung gibt und es kann nicht sein
dass es allein ein umweltministerium
macht sondern die klimafrage ist die
wettbewerbsfrage unser zeit auch für den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland und
deswegen muss die nächste
bundesregierung eine klima regierung
sein dafür wurden wir grün gewählt aber
das ist auch der auftrag für alle
anderen parteien und die grundlage für
unsere gespräche weil es eben so eine
essentielle frage auch für die zukunft
und die modernisierung unseres landes
ist stimmt es eigentlich dass man sich
bereits auf robert habeck als
vizekanzler geeinigt hat intern das
schreiben kollegen ja nach dem wahlabend
wird immer viel geschrieben
wir gehen sehr sortiert in diese
gespräche wir haben unsere internen
fragen alle vorher geklärt aber jetzt
ist der moment wirklich dafür zu sorgen
dass wir ein aufbruch schaffen wir haben
eine verantwortung in diesem land
deutschland zu modernisieren und das
werden robert habeck und ich als spitzen
sondierungsteam für unsere partei tun
wenn in den kommenden verhandlungen zu
wenig grüne politik rauskommt sagen sie
dann auch lieber nicht regieren als
schlecht regieren dieses land braucht
einen aufbruch und natürlich wenn wir
jetzt sondieren sind die zukunftsfragen
die entscheidenden gradmesser für die
nächste bundesregierung wir können ich
acht jahre weiter so dahin dümpeln wir
haben es bei der digitalisierung in den
schulen gesehen wir haben es mit den
investitionen in unserer land gesehen
und da gibt es zwischen den drei
parteien die jetzt miteinander gespräche
führen unterschied aber gerade bei der
frage auf was bedeutet eigentlich für
zukünftige generation
der starke gesellschaft haben wir zum
beispiel auch mit der fdp ja
schnittmengen im bildungsbereich oder
aber auch bei der frage einer modernen
gesellschaft einer vielfältigen
gesellschaft vielen dank für das
gespräch frau berg dankte ebenso
auch wenn die spd stärkste kraft ist das
rennen um die kanzlerschaft ist offen
beide kandidaten sowohl spd kandidat
scholz wie auch cdu-kandidat laschet
versuchen eine koalition zu schmieden
beide wollen mit den grünen und der fdp
reden auch wenn in der union offen
ausgesprochen wird dass es keinen
anspruch auf regierungsbildung gibt wie
geht es jetzt weiter christian hübscher
es hat etwas von paralleluniversum die
union gestern abend nach 16 jahren
kanzlerschaft sehen so verlierer aus von
armin laschet will auch am tag nach der
großen niederlage nicht beiträgen betont
wieder dass es weiter möglich sei eine
regierung unter seiner führung zu bilden
keine partei kann aus diesem klaren
ergebnis für sich einen
regierungsauftrag ableiten auch wir
nicht auch die spd nicht klar ist
kanzler wird in deutschland der der eine
mehrheit im deutschen bundestag hinter
sich bringt
regierungsauftrag ist kein formales
konzept aber trotzdem muss man natürlich
den kontext der wahl sehen die union hat
historisch stark verloren armin laschet
hat persönlich schlechte werte es wäre
schon eine kommunikative herausforderung
den menschen zu vermitteln warum er
jetzt der kanzler der bundesrepublik
sein soll nicht olaf scholz entsprechend
verwundert reibt man sich im willy
brandt haus die augen
ich war gestern abend schon sehr
irritiert über den auftritt von herrn
laschet und der cdu wenn ich denke schon
dass bei einem so historischen bei einer
so historischen wahlniederlage der cdu
doch ein wenig demut angesagt ist der
auftrag den wir bekommen haben von den
wählern und wlan und er ist sehr
eindeutig eine regierung zusammen mit
grünen und fdp zu bilden und das wollen
wir jetzt auch ein zorniger sächsische
cdu ministerpräsident kommt nach berlin
in seinem land sind fast alle
direktmandate an die fdp gegangen
kretschmann spricht heute klartext mit
seiner partei
ich würde dass dieses ergebnis ein
glücklichste saß er für die union in
deutschlands ist und die grundhaltung
dass wir weitermachen wie bisher muss
ins verderben führen deswegen braucht es
jetzt erst einmal ein innehalten die cdu
diese wahl verloren und wirklich scheint
im laufe des tages bei manchen in der
union ein umdenken einzusetzen regieren
gerne aber nicht um jeden preis außerdem
platz 2 ergibt sich kein anspruch kein
anspruch auf eine regierungsbildung das
sind können wir nur ein angebot machen
wir stehen zu gesprächen bereit aber
auch mit demut keine frage denn wir
haben keine wahl gewonnen muss man klar
sagen tatsächlich hat es das schon drei
mal gegeben in der geschichte dass der
zweite erste wurde sowie 1976 als kurz
war die wahl gewinnt aber schmidt
kanzler wird ich will bundeskanzler
werden in dieser ganz konkreten
situation unsere beiden parteien spd und
fdp haben den wählern vorher gesagt dass
wir wieder zusammen gehen wollen dafür
haben wir eine mehrheit bekommen jamaika
oder opposition der union bleibt eine
einzige option für den machterhalt
und im studio begrüße ich den
kanzlerkandidaten der spd olaf scholz
guten abend gute nacht sie haben die
wahl gewonnen hat armin laschet ihn
schon gratuliert bisher nicht könnte das
daran liegen daß er selbst denkt noch
bundeskanzler werden zu können mit
jamaika geht es jetzt darum wer mehr
bietet für spd für fdp und grünen oder
herr laschet über duncan und der wägung
von laschet kann ich nichts sagen ich
kann sagen was ich verstehe aus dem
votum der wählerinnen und wähler die
haben gesagt die spd soll stärkste
partei sein aus vielen umfragen kann man
auch sehen dass sich noch viel mehr
wünschen dass sich der nächste kanzlerin
bundesrepublik deutschland werden als
spd gewählt haben und drei parteien
haben diese bei diesem wahlgang stimmen
dazu bekommt die spd die grünen und die
fdp und deshalb müssen wir den auftrag
annehmen eine regierung zu bilden das
geht auch wenn man sich die programme
der parteien man schaut fdp und grüne
wollen ja vor verhandeln das klingt so
als ob die beiden sich darauf
verständigen wer unter ihm kanzler
werden kann was macht sie zuversichtlich
dass sie das rennen machen ich finde
dass regierungsbildung so stattfinden
müssen dass die parteien die dann
miteinander regieren sich vertrauen das
muss ja lange halten ich finde auch eine
regierung die antritt muss auch das ziel
haben wiedergewählt zu werden sowie in
der schwarz gelben koalition 2 9 bis 13
von der gurkentruppen debatte mal
abgesehen soll es nicht zugehen das muss
schon etwas seriöser sein und deshalb
habe ich mir fest vorgenommen dass wir
genau das zu stande bringen es gibt ja
schnittmengen die spd ist eine partei
die sich für den fortschritt in unserer
gesellschaft einsetzt für mehr respekt
dafür dass für unser land modernisieren
dass wir den menschen gemacht mit
klimawandel aufhalten auch die grünen
haben eine fortschritts vorstellung die
sich in dem fall sehr mit der frage des
klimawandels beschäftigt und auch bei
der fdp ist es so dass sie solche fragen
thematisiert bürgerrechte spielen eine
rolle wie bei spd und grünen und auch
die technologische modernisierung des
landes und aus diesen
herausforderung kann man eine
schnittmenge entwickeln die dann auch
gutes für das land und nicht nur für die
parteien fdp chef lindner hat heute
sinngemäß gesagt im fehler die
vorstellungskraft was die spd im
anbieten könne von dem auch die
spd-linke dann begeistert wäre hat aber
nicht an punkt ich glaube das ist jetzt
darum geht dass wir das tun was die
bürger in bürger von uns erwarten
pragmatisch reagieren miteinander
vernünftige kompromisse schließen das
gehört zu den führungsaufgaben dem wir
in der demokratie haben auch dazu wir
haben ein sehr gutes ergebnis erzielt
wir haben uns mit schlechteren
ergebnissen mit anderen geeinigt dass
wenn wir mit diesem guten ergebnis auch
gut hinkriegen ist eine erneute große
koalition die dann nicht mehr so groß
wäre unter spd-führung an option die
bürgerinnen bürger haben cdu/csu
abgewählt das ist eine botschaft die
alle verstehen müssen aber eben auch wir
und die cdu/csu zu allererst
sozial ökologisch liberal so soll die
ampel regieren kommt von ihnen von allem
ein bisschen und am ende nicht viel so
klingt das bei spd und fdp haben von
1969 bis
1982 gut regiert also sozial liberale
koalition
es hat eine gute koalition zwischen spd
und grünen gegeben von 1998 bis 2005 und
wenn jetzt diese drei parteien zusammen
regieren um die herausforderung der
zwanziger jahre dieses jahrhunderts zu
lösen dann ist das etwas was gute
grundlagen auf erfahrung in der
vergangenheit aber auch gute aufgaben
für die zukunft vielen dank für das
gespräch hier im studio olaf scholz
schönen dank
und das münchen zugeschaltet ist uns
jetzt csu chef markus söder guten abend
schön
guten amt auch die csu hat kräftig
federn gelassen wie viel soll da steckt
da drin
wir haben in der tat auch ein
enttäuschendes ergebnis erzielt aber in
der relation haben sind wir mit einem
blauen auge davon gekommen wir haben von
46 wahlkreisen 45 geholt davon in den
großstädten überragend abgeschnitten in
münchen drei von vier in nürnberg beide
es ist schon sehr beachtlich im
vergleich grad national zu vielen
anderen trotzdem sind wir nicht
zufrieden aber wir müssen das ergebnis
annehmen analysieren und daraus die
richtigen schlüsse ziehen die union hat
man den eindruck schwankt gerade
zwischen demut und macht sehnsucht kann
armin laschet nach dieser wahl klatsche
noch kanzler werden wir haben daraus
keinen moralischen führungsanspruch
abzuleiten aus dem wahlergebnis
allerdings teile ich die auffassung von
herrn scholz nicht also so ein
erdrutschsieg ist es nicht für die spd
sie liegt eineinhalb prozent oder 1,7
prozent vor der union es ist kein
gigantischer vorsprung und jetzt ist
einfach demokratisch notwendig zu reden
wir machen ein angebot mit grünen und
fdp zu reden denn ich glaube dass die
ampel viele schwierigkeiten herr scholz
hat vorhin gesagt sozial liberal war rot
grün war toll beide regierungszeiten von
schmidt und schröder endet mit millionen
von arbeitslosen und hoher inflation
also die bilanzen waren da nicht so gut
und deswegen ist es auch die dringende
verpflichtung zu reden zu versuchen eine
alternative zu einem solchen ampel
modell zu dicke von fehlentscheidungen
inhaltlicher und personeller art spricht
sachsens cdu ministerpräsident
kretschmann hat er recht
der wahlkampf war kein muster wahlkampf
da gab es von anfang an schwierigkeiten
man dafür nicht vergessen die cdu zwei
mal den parteivorsitzenden gewechselt
nach angela merkel mit jeweils schweren
kampfkandidaturen dann gab es eine
debatte im april auch um die richtige
entscheidung und da war schon viele
herausforderungen in diesem wahlkampf
drin aber es bringt jetzt nichts nur
zurückzuschauen man muss in der tat
allerdings analysieren wo die schwächen
sind natürlich muss das soziale das
ökologische profil gestärkt werden alte
kompetenzen wirtschafts und
sicherheitspolitik erneuert und gestärkt
werden und da haben wir noch eine menge
aufgaben vor uns aber richtig erneuern
kann man sich am besten in einer
regierung das ist ein impuls deswegen
wäre es schon wichtig dass wir jetzt
seriöse gespräche führen ich sage aber
auch wir werden uns nicht anbiedern und
wir werden auch keine endlos und jungen
machen und es darf auch nicht zu einer
entkernung der union führen also nach
dem motto hauptsache regieren um jeden
preis es müssen schon auch die inhalte
stimmen deswegen müssen die auch
klarmachen wie souverän und wie klar wir
den führungsanspruch dokumentieren auch
inhaltlich vielen dank für das gespräch
markus söder
so oder so stehen uns politisch
spannende wochen und monate bevor es ist
eine kräftige machtverschiebung die in
diesem wahlergebnis liegt manche nennen
es ein erdbeben
jedenfalls finden sich beide einst große
volksparteien deutlich unter 30 prozent
wieder und die vermeintlich kleinen
potenziellen partner sind gewachsen mit
den zahlen auch ihr selbstbewusstsein
was ist da passiert woran hat es gelegen
hat dass deutschland schon jetzt
verändert auch im flur
es ist gewählt und fast alles ausgezählt
aber wer wählte wen und vor allem warum
bei den direktmandaten verfärbt sich die
landkarte zugunsten der spd deutlich
mehr rot als 2017 die union verliert
wahlkreise im osten vor allem in
thüringen und sachsen ist es außerdem
die afd die unionsfraktionen schleift
selbst ihr wahlkreis ging diesmal an die
spd nach über 30 jahren fast
exemplarisch wer vorher immer merkel
wählte entschied sich diesmal nicht
immer für die union mit dem kandidaten
laschet
und dass der seiner partei eine hilfe
war glaubt nur elf prozent der
wählerinnen und wähler
56 prozent sagen er schadete ganz anders
der konkurrent fast 70 prozent hielten
olaf scholz für die spd für hilfreich
[Musik]
sympathieträger olaf scholz wien konnte
er für sich und sozialdemokratie
begeistern
nun vor allem die älteren machten sich
für die spd auf den weg ins wahllokal
bei den jungen keine 20 prozent ab
mittleren alter wird es besser und bei
den über 60-jährigen macht die spd die
meisten punkte früher waren die eher den
konservativen treu die jungen weder für
spd noch cdu ein matchwinner bei dieser
bundestagswahl der unter 30 ist fühlte
sich nicht wirklich angesprochen von den
parteien werk rocco die union verliert
in dieser gruppe sogar 13 prozent an
stimmen die spd reißt keine bäume aus
favoriten der generation merkel fdp und
grüne 19 prozent für gelb 23 prozent für
grün bei 30 für einen einst erträumten
wahlsieg reicht das trotzdem nicht die
alten an der urne prägten am ende das
ergebnis dieser bundestagswahl kanzler
macher heißt nun die rolle die grünen
und liberalen zugedacht wurde von
wählerinnen und wählern und die haben
den beiden die es jetzt werden wollen
ein rätsel aufgegeben das gelöst werden
will
und im studio begrüße ich die
politikwissenschaftlerin sabine kropf
guten abend guten abend die ära merkel
ist zu ende was folgt ist unklar was ist
da gestern passiert war das ein erdbeben
oder ein stück normalität ein erdbeben
würde ich nichts sagen wenn man die
wahlergebnisse in deutschland einordnet
in den europäischen vergleich dann sieht
man dass deutschland sich in gewisser
weise an gleicht das parteiensystem wird
fragmentierter und damit wächst auch die
zahl der koalitionsoptionen wir haben
uns nach 16 jahren merkel vielleicht
eben auch daran gewöhnt an eine
stabilität an der spitze der regierung
die aber nicht symptomatisch ist für die
entwicklung des parteiensystems
wahlsieger konnte man ja jetzt gerade
mit 25 prozent der stimmen werden
dahinter gibt es mehrere mittelgroße
parteien mit der aussicht auf ungewohnte
koalition sie haben gerade schon
angedeutet sehen sie darin auch eine
chance das kann eine chance bedeuten
nämlich dann wenn es gelingt die
unterschiedlichen profile zu einem
konsistenten regierungsprogramm
zusammenzubinden da stecken aber noch
viele tücken drin zb die frage nach der
regulierenden rolle des staates die drei
parteien ja teilweise sehr
unterschiedlich beantworten was sich
dann auch auswirken wird auf die frage
wie man wirtschaftspolitik und zum
beispiel umweltpolitik zusammen denkt
welche koalition rechnerisch stehen das
schauen wir uns hier noch mal kurz an
als basis für unser gespräch eine große
koalition aus spd und cdu csu wäre klar
möglich ebenfalls eine dreier koalition
aus spd grünen und fdp die sogenannte
ampel und ein dreier bündnis aus cdu/csu
grünen und fdp die sogenannte
jamaika-koalition
was folgt ist das wahrscheinlich zu
dieser bündnisse im augenblick spricht
viel für eine ampel und zwar deswegen
weil die spd als wenn auch knappe
wahlsiegerin aus dem rennen gestern
hervorgegangen ist und die cdu eine
historische niederlage eingefahren hat
zur großen koalition möchten beide
parteien nicht mehr zurück das wäre auch
gegenüber der eigenen anhängerschaft
schwer zu vermitteln und damit ist zwar
die derzeitige verhandlungssituation
noch offen aber wie gesagt viele spricht
im augenblick für eine ampel ein wort
noch zur linken sie ist an der
fünf-prozent-hürde gescheitert ist das
ein schwäche moment oder etwas
strukturelles es ist sicherlich ein
schwäche moment aber dahinter stehen
strukturelle probleme die linkspartei
hat in den vergangenen jahren viele
ihrer mitglieder durch überalterung
verloren das waren diejenigen die in
ostdeutschland sich als kümmerer auch
auf der lokalen ebene um die verankerung
der partei gesorgt haben und
gleichzeitig sind die westdeutschen
landesverbände die wesentliche
ideologischer sind innerhalb der partei
stärker geworden sie haben an gewicht
gewonnen vielen dank für den moment wir
sprechen gleich nochmal weiter zum thema
afd wir schauen uns aber erst noch mal
einen film an vieles war in diesem
wahlkampf auf die drei kanzlerkandidaten
konzentriert und für viele bürgerinnen
und bürger sind sie hoffnungsträger oder
anlass zur sorge menschen haben
mitgefiebert auf ihre partei und ihre
kandidaten gehofft und gesetzt und sind
jetzt zufrieden oder frustriert je
nachdem wir haben uns an der basis um
gehört in görlitz münchen und potsdam
im berühmten wahlkreis 61 erst der spd
mitgliederversammlung nach der wahl olaf
scholz und annalena baerbock rangen hier
beide um ein direktmandat olaf scholz
hat es mit deutlichem vorsprung geholt
christina bauermeister von der
ortsgruppe ludwigsfelder ist einfach nur
froh
man muss sich ja mal vor augen führen
dass wir vor vier jahren mit meiner
schüler den einzigen wahlkreis für die
spd im osten überhaupt geholt haben und
jetzt habe ich allein in brandenburg
alle zehn direktmandate geholt von da
her ist es für uns ein sehr sehr schöner
tag also mir persönlich würde am herzen
liegen dass wir eine koalition bekommen
die nicht von der cdu dominiert wird am
besten eine koalition ohne die cdu da
brauche ich kein geheimnis draus zu
machen und ich glaube dass das auch
jetzt dem mehrheit in der spd so sieht
wird trotzdem nun kanzler stadt nicht
weit von olaf scholz wohnsitz liegt das
lokal grünen der potsdamer innenstadt
das wahllokal der grünen wird geputzt
und bald dicht gemacht nun steht die
nächste runde an wer kann und will mit
wem die grünen wissen sie haben diesmal
viel bessere karten
dass jetzt sofort maßnahmen für den
klimaschutz umgesetzt werden und dass
die grünen starke stimme für den
klimaschutz sind und dafür sind wir ja
auch angetreten für eine echte klima
regierung und für einen echten aufbruch
gerade was die klimaschutzfragen angeht
da ist ja auch die spd ja noch so ein
bisschen nicht so auf dem weg richtung
15 grad was den kohleausstieg angeht da
müssen wir auf jeden fall noch hart
verhandeln denke ich aber
ich glaube da können wir bestimmt
zusammenkommen gegensatz zu der cdu ich
glaube der tut auch die opposition mal
ganz gut die nächsten vier jahre
klimaschutzes unser ja unser fokus denn
wird alle haben sollten und alle
verfolgen müssen und natürlich möchte
ich auch das soziale gerechtigkeit
besser ausgebaut wird eine ampel
koalition regierte in brandenburg
zumindest schon direkt nach der wende
mit bündnis 90/die später zu bündnis 90
die grünen wurden
er hat sein direktmandat verloren als
einziger in der csu und sie hatten für
ihn gekämpft am tag danach ist bei den
wahlkämpfern in münchner süden der
schmerz deutlich zu spüren
das plakat an scheidung man sich denkt
wir seien raus
ein ungewohntes gefühl für csu
mitglieder zum ersten mal seit zwölf
jahren gingen nicht mehr alle
direktmandate an die csu und erstmals
überhaupt haben die grünen in bayern ein
direktmandat geholt genau hier in
münchen süd woran hat es gelegen hat es
am ende die die kampagne linksrutsch
verhindern und so die war gut die hat
auch gezogen das haben wir im infostand
gemerkt wenn man nicht so viel zeit
verplempert hätten mit irgendwelche
wer ist der bessere sondern uns auch
fachthemen konzentriert hätten dann
glaube ich dass man nur andere stimmung
gehabt hätten auch dieser wahlkämpfer
hat eine veränderte stimmung gespürt und
ist über den verlust nur eines
wahlkreises sogar erleichtert wir hätten
viel schlimmer das erwartet wer vor vier
wochen gewählt waren in münchen hätten
uns erscheinen die streiche oder vier
wahlkreise verloren und das wie eine
zäsur gewesen und deswegen sind wir noch
mit einem blauen auge zwar schmerzlich
aber noch davon gekommen zusammen
gekämpft zusammen verloren und jetzt
zimmer zusammen den karren wieder aus
dem dreck sozusagen die nächste
landtagswahl ist ja auch schon in zwei
jahren
fast jeder dritte wähler hier im
sächsischen görlitz gab der afg seine
stimme in keinem anderen deutschen
wahlkreis holte die partei mehr und
görlitz steht nur beispielhaft für ein
bundesland in dem die afg fast
flächendeckend die meisten zweitstimmen
holte und auch zehn von 16 wahlkreisen
direkt gewann reaktionen die afg schon
passen und das wasser aus einem
erschreckt oder was mich traurig macht
dass es so weit kommt ist
auf jeden fall polizei wird reduziert
wir haben sehr viel kriminalität hier
von diebstahl angefangen
und damit sind die leute sicherlich und
zufrieden
sebastian witte sieht die afg als neue
volkspartei bestätigt doch auch sie
hatte auf hohem niveau verloren in
sachsen und auf bundesebene
warum dieses schwert des
verfassungsschutzes was die regierenden
führen gegen uns das ist nicht von
vorteil für uns trotz alledem haben wir
eine stabile wählerbasis und auf die
konnten wir uns zurückziehen haben wir
uns konsolidiert der görlitzer
sozialwissenschaftler bei kollmorgen
sieht inzwischen ein festes afd milieu
in sachsen wie in ganz deutschland ein
milieu das auch nicht verschwinden wird
aber die cdu kann davon ein teil
abschöpfen auch im übrigen die linke ja
also das sind populistische grundmotive
und grundeinstellungen die wähler müssen
nicht nur die afg wählen doch eine
prognose wie sich die politischen
gewichte in deutschland und in sachsen
demnächst verschieben sei derzeit
schwierig
die afd ist in thüringen und sachsen
stärkste partei geworden was verschiebt
sich da man kann sagen dass die afg
immer noch protestpartei sie bindet aber
mehr und mehr das wählerklientel zb
durch kompetenz werde im bereich innere
sicherheit und migration und sie spricht
besonders auch wähler an die angst vor
veränderungen haben also angst vor
statusverlust und wenn man sich die
ostdeutsche geschichte der letzten 30
jahre betrachtet dann ist das auch
verständlich und gerade dieser wahlkampf
sprach ja sehr viel von veränderungen
und von mandl frau professor of crop
herzlichen dank für den besuch und die
analyse bitte hier es gab aber auch noch
zwei landtagswahlen auf die wir schauen
können und wir gucken zuerst mal nach
berlin dort sah es lange zeit nach einem
kopf-an-kopf-rennen zwischen spd und
grünen aus am ende aber setzte sich die
spd-spitzenkandidatin franziska giffey
durch damit bekommt die hauptstadt
erstmals eine regierende bürgermeisterin
schauen wir auch hier auf die zahlen die
spd 21,4 prozent die grünen 18,9 die cdu
18,1 linke 14% afd acht fdp 7,2 was das
für die hauptstadt bedeutet zeigt uns
sylvia bleßmann
das rote rathaus hat franziska giffey
erfolgreich für die spd verteidigt nun
sucht sie für ihren weg der mitte eine
passende koalition wir werden in den
gremien besprechen was funktionieren
kann wie wir die möglichst großen
schnittmengen haben mit dem programm das
wir als sozialdemokraten in berlin
beschlossen haben und natürlich kann
eine möglichkeit übrigens auch in
rheinland-pfalz er erfolgreich ist auch
ein weg für berlin sein knapp verfehlt
hat bettina jarasch der regierungsspitze
aber mit an der macht bleiben sollten
die grünen meint sie am besten im rot
rot grünen bündnis sie sind die einzigen
die deutlich zugelegt haben in dieser
wahl und zwar aus einer
regierungsverantwortung heraus also ja
es braucht mehr grün in der stadt das
haben die wählerinnen und wähler
deutlich gesagt und ich freue mich dass
heben deshalb auf verhandlungen mit der
spd für jarasch gehört das eindeutige
worte und des volksentscheides unbedingt
in koalitionsgespräche etwa 57 prozent
der berliner hatten sich für
enteignungen ausgesprochen die linke
sieht darin für den neuen senat den
klaren auftrag ein gesetz zu erarbeiten
das recht sicher funktioniert der
volksentscheiden und so überwältigend
positiv aufgenommen worden ist
angenommen worden es glaube ich würde
sich egal welche regierung ist zukünftig
gibt diese regierung ernsthaft mit
diesem ergebnis auseinander setzen
müssen mit der fdp wäre so ein
enteignungsgesetz nicht zu verhandeln
die spd muss jetzt entscheiden ob sie
tatsächlich das jetzt umsetzt was sie
vor der wahl angekündigt hat nämlich
einen weg der erneuerung in der stadt zu
gehen und das wird nicht mit
rot-rot-grün gelingen
aus sicht der cdu hat die spd schon den
raum geöffnet für eine koalition der
mitte kai wegner ist optimistisch dabei
zu sein die chance ist da dass wir einen
wirklichen neustart einen wirklichen
politikwechsel in dieser stadt
hinbekommen die spd ist nicht dafür
gewählt worden in berlin um rot-rot-grün
fortzusetzen doch sie ist als stärkste
kraft gewählt wurden und wird nun mit
vier parteien verhandeln
auch in mecklenburg-vorpommern ist
gewählt worden und da ist die lage etwas
deutlicher das bild ist eindeutiger spd
spitzenkandidatin manuela schwesig hat
die wahl klar für sich entschieden mit
einem starken ergebnis von 39,6 prozent
für die spd bleibt sie an den hebeln der
macht und canon entscheiden mit wem sie
weiterregieren will schauen wir uns die
zahlen noch mal genauer an die spd kommt
auf 39,6 prozent die afg auf 16,7 cdu
13,3 linke 9,9 grüne 6,3 fdp 5,8
konsequenzen aus dem schlechten
abschneiden der cdu hat jetzt der
landesvorsitzende und spitzenkandidat
michael sack gezogen er hat mit
sofortiger wirkung seinen rücktritt
erklärt der hat mosebach
die nacht war kurz in schwerin doch
diesen jubel in der berliner
parteizentrale holt sich manuela
schwesig gerne ab im gepäck ein klarer
wahlsieg ich bin sehr froh dass ich
heute wieder hier sein darf dass sich
den wahlsieg aus dem nordosten
mitgebracht hat und ich möchte der
partei danken allen die in dieser zeit
immer an unserer seite waren und ich
möchte vor allem den mitarbeitern
mitarbeitern danken wir alle wissen wir
haben nicht immer hier gestanden mit
drei wahlsiegen manuela schwesig hat der
rückenwind der bundestagswahl genutzt
ihm hat er geschadet michael sack von
der cdu am abend tritt er als
landesvorsitzender zurück seiner
nominierung als spitzenkandidat kam spät
ihm war es nicht gelungen gegen schwesig
zu punkten am ende fuhr er das
schlechteste cdu-ergebnis im nordosten
ein ich glaube für michael sack haben
wir sehr sehr wenig zeit gehabt ihn auch
dementsprechend aufzubauen michael sagt
er ist ein ausgezeichneter kandidaten
ein wirklich menschlich charakterlich
sehr feiner mensch hätte es durchaus
verdient aber wir haben auch wenig zeit
für ihn gehabt die afg verliert zwar
vier prozent wird aber trotzdem
zweitstärkste kraft im landtag von der
schwäche der cdu konnte sie offenbar
nicht profitieren bei den 60-jährigen
aufwärts haben wir noch erhebliche
probleme sie für uns zu gewinnen das ist
liegt in der natur der sache natürlich
da ist man sozusagen erstmal skeptisch
neuem gegenüber oftmals das ist klar
auch bei frauen haben wir nachholen so
zusagen müssten wir haben sehr großen
nachholbedarf
die linke hat stimmen eingebüßt steht
bereit für eine koalition mit der spd
allerdings nicht um jeden preis
natürlich ist bei uns die bildung ganz
ganz wichtig die nummer eins und
natürlich auch der kampf gegen armut wir
sind das armuts land nummer eins und da
müssen wir endlich wegkommen und das
sind für uns prioritäten in den
verhandlungen wenn denn welche geführt
werden eine koalition mit manuela
schwesigs spd könnten sich auch grüne
und liberale vorstellen viele optionen
und für die frau die angekündigt hat
mindestens die nächsten fünf jahre in
der schweriner staatskanzlei zu bleiben
und wir schauen noch mal auf die
kanzlerkandidaten scholz laschet und
bernburg genauer gesagt wir schauen in
deren heimat was sagen und fühlen die
menschen dort wie bewegt sie der
wahlausgang matthias kubica hat sich in
hamburg aachen und paten sind umgehört
der nächste kanzler ein hamburger
wahlsieger scholz regierte an alster und
elbe sieben jahre als erster
bürgermeister
könig olaf hat erst hamburg von der cdu
erobert und jetzt das ganze land
kommentiert die presse
hier in altona wohnt er wenn er mal da
ist der vielleicht bald ampel kanzler
soll es werden oder lieber nicht was
sagen die nachbarn
nicht unbedingt nicht auch wenn da ja
fast unser nachbar ist ja ich freue mich
natürlich für ihn ich denke das ist auf
jeden fall das was er sich für uns
gewünscht hat für hamburg und für
deutschland wenn ein bisschen gespalten
auf der einen seite finde ich das
ziemlich gut mit herrn scholz auf der
anderen seite sind aber auch sachen
passiert wie der g 20 zum beispiel was
mir nicht so geschmeckt hat also was ich
ihm definitiv zugestehe es eine große
erfahrung und professionalität und nur
ruhe auch kiosk-besitzer showbühnen
kennt scholz als eher ruhigen kunden ihn
als kanzler klar
ist auch unser nachbar
also wir können dass der weg ins
kanzleramt werde für scholz aber
bestimmt noch kompliziert befürchtet
hätten
ich schätze wirklich das wird sehr
schwer für olaf scholz die sich da
durchzusetzen
bei der fdp wird glaube ich richtig
zögern und so darf guck mal missraten
weit weg von herrn günstiges betritt
olaf scholz zur selben zeit die große
bühne in berlin um hanseatisch kühl zu
verkünden was mit fdp und grünen jetzt
vor ihm liegt große aufgaben denen wir
uns stellen wollen und über die wir
gerne mit den beiden anderen parteien
ins gespräch kommen wollen um dann so
schnell wie möglich auch tatsächlich
eine regierung zu bilden ganz im westen
in armin laschet heimat aachen hat man
es kommen sehen am tag danach beschreibt
die lokale zeitungen seine niederlage so
historisch schwacher unionskandidat spd
profitiert
dieses büdchen gehört einem laschet fan
am samstag noch nachdem
wahlkampfabschluss mit angela merkel
kaufte der kanzlerkandidat beinah
samaras wie immer zigarillos ich habe
ihm die augen gedrückt oder gewünscht
sollten jetzt nicht noch länger
strapazieren stehen mal das war schon
stressig der ganzen tag und heute am tag
nach der wahl das ima was will wissen
was seine kunden vom ergebnis halten
ergebnis
sie mit ihrem wahlergebnis zufrieden
nicht so
hier werden wir als ganzer gewünscht
am ende aber könnte es der aachener doch
noch ins kanzleramt schaffen wie wird es
wohl weitergehen jamaika warum man sagen
war ist auch hierfür bloß nicht mit der
cdu die soll mal in die opposition ich
hoffe dass es eine von den beiden dreier
bündnissen gibt bin ich also ziemlich
offen ich hoffe einfach dass es für
deutschland gut ist und das lege ich
ihnen da oben in die hände und sonst
kein für einen rheinländer kommt das ja
sprichwörtlich wie es kommt und dann
geht es immer gut darauf setzt laschet
in berlin und will kanzler von jamaika
werden keiner sollte so auftreten als
wenn er alleine entscheiden könnte wie
er eine regierung bildet und deshalb
sind gespräche mit möglichen partnern
jetzt erforderlich wir müssen uns da auf
augenhöhe begegnen
und wie ist die stimmung in pattensen
südlich von hannover im ortsteil
schulenburg wuchs annalena baerbock auf
verhaltener jubel trotz rekordergebnis
schreibt die zeitung bei der die
kanzlerkandidatin mal praktikantin war
in der politik ist sie zumindest für
platz eins aus dem spiel haben die
grünen mit der jungen niedersächsin auf
die falsche gesetzt
es gibt bessere sie hat zwar
selbstbewusstsein aber meiner meinung
nach keine kompetenz jaha weg wäre
besser gewesen kompetenter hat erfahrung
und hat sich auch selbst auf die beine
gestellt sie ist muss noch ein bisschen
mehr erfahrung sammeln ich glaube sie
wird weitermachen
sie ist kämpferin wird weitermachen und
ich glaube da gewinnen wird dann auf
ihrer seite sein die grünen wollen sich
auf jeden fall beweisen in einer
koalition als kellner nun doch nicht als
koch
die menschen in diesem land wollen
besser regiert werden das ist unsere
verantwortung und unser anspruch dass
jetzt in die nächste bundesregierung mit
einzubringen und das ist der auftrag und
dem ich vorhin gesprochen habe auch wenn
wir das jetzt in anderer rolle sind als
wir das ursprünglich geplant haben der
dreikampf ist jetzt ein duell scholz
oder laschet hanseat oder rheinländer
wer wird sich geschickter ins kanzleramt
verhandeln
es war ein langer wahlkampf für ein
neues kapitel nach der ära merkel
mindestens schemenhaft ist zu erkennen
dass es ein weiter so nicht geben wird
die zeichen stehen auf wandel das
betrifft koalitionen personen themen ob
daraus ein aufbruch wird bleibt
abzuwarten die grundlage dafür haben die
wählerinnen und wähler jedenfalls gelegt
das war unser zdf spezial weitere
informationen auf zdf heute.de und
später im heute journal vielen dank für
ihr interesse auf wiedersehen
[Musik]